In Turkey, Kurds march in protest of the airstrikes...
...sanctioned by the Turkish government.
In Iraq, sales of the national flag grow because of protests against corruption...
...and lack of services in the capital and the southern provinces.
In China, President Xi Jinping holds a welcoming ceremony...
...for his Kazakhstan counterpart Nursultan Nazarbayev in Beijing.
Police in Thailand receive a large cash reward for catching a suspect...
...they have yet to tie directly to the recent bombing.
And finally from Britain, the government announces a multimillion-pound program...
...to refurbish its nuclear submarine base in Scotland.